[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a un Arreux je m'y colle dans le
petit pois de saint-oman je t'attrape et
tu Tices je me cache à toi maintenant il
y a un arbre
Pich dans le petit poid de saintamant
vous tournez l' de FO piégeon vole vol
vol au V dessus l'arbre boisson vole et
le tien voilà le printemps il a nos 15
ans qui s'affolent dans le petit mois de
saintamant et sous l'orbre sans parole
tu me baisses amoureusement et dans
l'herbe Jon vole et s'envole le rêve
d'enfant mais c'est un bonjour tête
folle loin du petit poid de saintamant
et loin du temps de l'école je suis
parti à le vol au vent bonjour l'AR mon
belomme
je reviens chez le cœur contant sous tes
branches qui se penchent je retrouve mes
rêves d'enfant il a un arbre si je meurs
je veux qu'on m'y couche doucement qu'il
soit ma dernière deur dans le petit pois
de Saint Amant qu'il soit ma dernière
demeur dans le petit pois de Saint il y
a un arbre ple et sans il y a un
arbre
[Applaudissements]